bill cosby once again a free man after a  stunning court reversal bill cosby been  released from prison and returning home  pennsylvania's highest court overturned  the 83 year old sexual assault  conviction  on a technicality cosby was convicted in  2018 of  drugging and molesting andrea constand  in 2004.  pennsylvania supreme court says cosby  should never have been charged because  a former district attorney made a deal  in exchange for testimony in a civil  case  brought by constand cosby would not be  facing criminal charges  bill cosby relied on that promise  he could not take the fifth amendment to  say that he could incriminate himself  because he was never going to be  prosecuted the comic  and actor was sentenced to three to 10  years at least 60 other women stepped  forward with stories similar to  constance  so far prosecutors have not said whether  they will appeal